have a seizure  what is it you know I think it's a key  hi chris is a really gentle guy  respectful guy we love each other an  awful lot Jim you know how are you and  Danielle Jim has had sex no does on a  body  I don't know why he's acting this way I  think you should told him do you mind  terribly if I went back up to bed for  half an hour Allah protect as long as  youth do you like to come with me  [Music]  what if next time I'm not sure how much  of its fear or how much of its  anticipation are you still in love with  Danielle what's your code why do you  want to know I need to make sure that  you're not up to something I think you  might be I've been bit temperamental  why do you expect me to socialize with  people that I have no interest in maybe  a little bit - no idea  and I like this  you